es ist ein albtraum wenn ein
polizeieinsatz so endet wie jetzt in
dortmund dort hat die polizei selbst
tödliche schüsse abgegeben und der tote
ist erst 16 jahre alt was ist da
passiert bei diesem einsatz in der
dortmunder nordstadt
dramatische szenen in dortmund ein
jugendlicher greift die polizei mit
einem messer an die beamten erschießen
ihn der tote ist erst 16 jahre alt um
16.25 spitzt sich der einsatz in der
dortmunder nordstadt dramatisch zu
holsteiner straße auf dem abgesperrten
kirchengelände trifft mindestens eine
kugel den teenager laut
bild-informationen ein senegalese er
bricht schwer getroffen auf dem
kirchengelände st antonius zusammen wo
er in einer jugendgruppe lebte der 16
jährige kommt in die klinik noch während
der not-operation hört sein herz auf zu
schlagen bild weiß der jugendliche hat
zunächst in suizidaler absicht das
messer angesetzt stiche in den eigenen
bauch angedeutet die beamten wollten ihn
mit einem taser stoppen dann soll er im
hof der kirche aber plötzlich auf sie
losgegangen sein und
wir sprechen jetzt mit bild chefreporter
frank schneider dort in dortmund am
tatort größte die ich frank diese
tödlichen polizeischüsse die schlagen
inzwischen ruhe und der tote
schwarzafrikaner der tote erst 16 jahre
alt nach allem was du weisst gab es für
die polizei wirklich keine andere
möglichkeit als auf diesen jungen zu
schießen
das können wir noch nicht genau
endgültig sagen aber momentan sieht es
wirklich so aus als wenn es eine
notwehrsituation gewesen wäre ich stehe
hier an der stelle wo gestern diese
schüsse gefallen wir können einmal
zeigen es ist hier die st antonius
gemeinde und dort ist auch die kirche
der kollege filmt einmal in diesem
innenhof und in diesem innenhof hat
gestern der polizeieinsatz begonnen sah
es nämlich so dass nämlich dort dieser
jugendliche 16 jahre aus dem senegal mit
einem messer gestanden hat die anwohner
und auch mitarbeiter einer jugendhilfe
gruppe die hier an dieser
kirchengemeinde in einem haus ist haben
die polizei verständigt und auch den
rettungsdienst weil dieser junge
psychische auffälligkeiten zeigte schon
den letzten tagen und eben auch geäußert
er wolle sich um dann soll er gestern
hier nur verstanden haben mit einem sehr
langen messer man spricht von einer
klingenlänge von 15 bis 20 zentimetern
und hat angedroht sich selbst getötet
hat immer wieder stichbewegungen
richtung bauch angedeutet so sagen die
augenzeugen und die polizeibeamten und
dann wollten die polizei waren ihn
eigentlich retten sie wollten verhindern
dass er sich umbringt und dann ist
folgendes passiert sie haben dann als
sie merken er lässt sich nicht beruhigen
er ist in so einer psychischen
ausnahmesituation erstmal fast break
eingesetzt das ist ja die niedriges der
eskalationsstufe das hat nichts bewirkt
dann sollen sie auch den taser das ist
ja nordrhein-westfalen relativ neu diese
these die die polizei auch hat
eingesetzt haben das soll auch nichts
gebracht haben und dann soll die
situation plötzlich total eskaliert sein
der jugendliche soll losgerannt sein auf
die polizeibeamten losgegangen sein mit
diesem messer und ist dann hier über
diesen zaun wir können das noch mal
zeigen wo wir gerade den hof gefilmt
haben und der kameramann kann dann noch
mal rüber schwenken dann sehen wir hier
am boden gleich nämlich die nummern die
sind hier noch angezeichnet wir sehen
hier einmal die nummer vier und ein
stück weiter sehen wir dann die nummer
fünf und sechs hier vorne im
sonnenschein und da ist es nämlich so
gewesen dass die polizeibeamten hier
dann geschossen haben dort lagen hülsen
daran sieht man wie auf die polizei dann
doch hat geschossen hat oder schießen
musste das müssen jetzt die ermittlungen
klären jedenfalls ist ja wohl über
diesen zaun und auch die polizeibeamten
die hier zur sicherung stand losgegangen
und die wussten sich in der situation
wohl nicht anders zu helfen als eben zu
schießen und die ermittlungen liegen
jetzt bei der polizei in recklinghausen
und bei der staatsanwaltschaft in
dortmund die obduktion wird heute mittag
sein und dann muss man genau klären
woran ist er gestorben wo es ja
getroffen worden wie viele kugeln haben
ihn getroffen und der einsatz
aufbereitet werden
franck weiß so zu den hintergründen
dieses jungens erst 16 jahre alt dort
offenbar auch untergebracht welche
informationen hast du über ihn über das
todesopfer
wir wissen bislang es handelt sich um
einen 16 jährigen jugendlichen aus dem
senegal der wohl als flüchtling
unbegleitet hier hingekommen ist
jedenfalls hat er in dieser wohngruppe
wohl alleine gelebt ob ihre familie
hatte sich wissen wir zum 10 zeit noch
nicht die kirchengemeinde möchte
momentan nichts sagen die stehen alle
unter großen schock weil sie eben auch
dem jugendlichen helfen wollten wussten
jetzt nicht gut deshalb ist denn diese
jugendhilfeeinrichtungen und das da
gestern so eskaliert ist damit konnte
keiner rechnen meinte die polizei
gerufen und den rettungsdienst der mitte
junge gerettet wird und am ende ist er
jetzt doch tot und das wollte eben
keiner und man merkt hier einen großen
schock in der kirchengemeinde und woher
der junge wirklich stammt aber hier auch
in dortmund vorgelebt hat das konnte uns
bislang noch keiner sagen bzw eben in
der kirchengemeinde wollte uns niemand
sagen weil sie sagen wir müssen erstmal
selber das erlebte von gestern abend
verarbeiten haben jetzt frank innerhalb
weniger tage viele tote nach
polizeieinsätzen in köln dort um die
ecke zuvor auch in frankfurt ein toter
nach einem polizeieinsatz jetzt dieser
fall in dortmund alles unterschiedliche
fälle und trotzdem diese ballung von
fällen innerhalb weniger tage dafür
spricht dass nach deiner erfahrung die
du immer ja ein enges ohr an der polizei
hass dafür dass die waffe möglicherweise
schneller gezückt wird ist das reiner
zufall oder spricht das dafür dass die
polizisten im einsatz aber noch häufiger
bedroht werden
also ich glaube die waffe wird häufiger
gezückt aber eben auf der gegenseite
nicht die polizeibeamten sie lernen ja
eben ganz bewusst in der ausbildung das
sogenannte nicht schießen es ist ja das
ziel der polizei beim auf keinen fall
die schusswaffe einzusetzen außer das
geht überhaupt nicht mehr anders und was
wir in den letzten jahren beobachtet
haben ist eine zunehmende
respektlosigkeit gegenüber
polizeibeamten und dazu eben auch immer
häufiger einsatz von waffen und dabei
handelt es sich häufig um ein messer das
war in köln ja nicht anders er hatte
einen schraubendreher und ein messer
hier hatte der jugendliche auch ein
messer und viel unterschätzen das gibt
ja ein aufschrei auch schon im social
media nach dem motto wie kann man auf
einen 16 jährigen schließen der ja nur
ein messer hat man muss wissen gerade in
der ausbildung wird das ja trainiert ein
sogenannter messer täter ist viel
gefährlicher häufiger als ein täter mit
einer schusswaffe weil die überwinden
halt kurze distanzen in ganz ganz
schneller ja in 230 kunden und die
polizeibeamten können sich gegner messer
kaum wehren sie können schlecht
eingreifen haben eben gehört eine
klingenlänge von 15 bis 20 zentimeter
diese messer wirken halt im ersten stich
möglicherweise tödlich und die beamten
tragen zwar schutzwesten ja aber wenn
zum beispiel ein messer eindringt
entlang der schutzweste dort wo der arm
raus kommt eben unter der schulter oder
eben auch ins gesicht oder in den hals
geht dann sind die polizei war
möglicherweise beim ersten stich tödlich
verletzt und deshalb müssen sie häufig
eben auch mit der schusswaffe agieren
und das ist ein großes problem genau
deshalb hatte die polizei in nordrhein
westfalen jetzt diesen tesa angeschafft
um eben eine niedrigere eskalationsstufe
zu haben um eben nicht schießen zu
müssen warum das gestern abend nicht
gereicht hat warum der jugendliche
offenbar unbeeindruckt war von diesem
thema das müssen jetzt noch mal die
ermittlungen und die obduktion klären
danke ganz kurz nach der die schlüssel
kann jetzt in dortmund aus einer
maschinenpistole sagt dass du uns und
das ist
ja das klingt erst mal ungewöhnlich aber
die polizei führt diese maschinenpistole
seit vielen jahren wieder mit früher
hatte die jeder streifenwagen
mittlerweile hat die polizei die auch
wieder dabei aufgrund der terrorgefahr
man muss aber wissen die polizei
erschießt die gleiche munition mit ihrer
dienstwaffe der dienstpistole wie auch
mit dieser maschinenpistole mp5 das ist
ein 9 9 millimeter patronen und man die
maschinenpistole wird häufig eingesetzt
bei größeren distanzen weil sie genauer
schießt weil man eben auch vermeiden
will den täter tödlich zu verletzen
erstmal noch kampfunfähig zu schießen
hier was gestern auch so dass die erste
meldung war der jugendliche ist zwar
schwer verletzt kommt ins krankenhaus
aber es besteht keine lebensgefahr warum
er dann drei stunden später in der
klinik während der not-op doch
verstorben ist das muss eben heute die
note die obduktion klären denn die
not-op ja damit das leben zu retten aber
genau dort ist er dann verstorben und da
muss man sehen ob es möglicherweise so
starke innere verletzungen waren ein
junge 16 jahre alt ein schwarzafrikaner
senegalese wird von der polizei
notwehrsituation in dortmund erschossen
danke für alle hintergründe an unseren
chefreporter frank schneider
[Musik]